you are now live with layer eight culture
tech thursday
What's up, y'all?
It's Thursday.
Tech Thursday.
Man.
It's a... It's an interesting day.
So... We talked about it last week.
Five point six.
That, uh... Five point...
GPT five point six is out.
So let's get into it.
Let me, uh...
Get my screen all situated.
Man.
Let's see.
Yeah, it's at it.
All right.
Straight to the OpenAI website.
Man.
some serious stuff here let me get some
uh give some that layer a culture radio
lo-fi playing
So GPT.
So if you haven't seen, there's a,
it's like a thirtysomething minute
presentation they did on it.
They have a bunch of updates as well.
The opening I made to GPT.
but if you look at this, let's see.
So, this chart is hard to read.
So that's half my six, so extra high.
API cost score,
fifty three point six percent.
This is the cost.
Okay.
Five point five, where is table?
Five point six.
Five point six Terra.
Five point six Luna.
It's a little confusing here.
I'm processing.
Where it is?
Why is this chart so hard to read?
Oh, okay.
I get now.
So we're see Claude is not on this
list here.
i'm not seeing cloud on this list but
down here browse comp multi-agent here we
go sec bench pro all right excuse me
awesome first time like i'm digesting all
this live and right here i didn't even
look at this before
Over the last few weeks,
users around the world have been testing
GPT-Five point six in the new ChatGPT.
You already met Hiroki.
Welcome back to him.
And then there was a couple in New
York who used GPT-Five point six to help
run a cereal business from their dining
room.
And their son, Ellis.
It's called cotton candy.
Not trying to glaze myself.
Personally, my favorite.
And then the mathematician in Poland who
used five point six to solve an unsolvable
problem.
But we'll get to all of that.
Let's start with Hiroki.
He used Five Point Six to automate the
opening and closing of his greenhouse
doors.
Five Point Six taught him which gadgets he
needed to purchase,
how to wire a Raspberry Pi,
and then how to install a motor.
Nice.
So this is a perfect example of the
user becoming the builder, right?
So he's using it as solving a problem
for him.
He learns how to use, um,
how to build using five point six.
So I noticed how at this point,
he's not just building, well,
of course he's building software,
but the software that he's building,
is interfacing with hardware to solve a
real-world problem.
So this is kind of cool.
Let's keep playing it.
And it worked.
Now,
Five Point Six is also helping people run
small businesses.
This is Jake.
He's on the Three Wishes team,
and he's showing us how he prompts the
model.
So I always start by saying,
please set a goal for yourself to do
this end to end.
Please use historical launches as like a
means to inform the dashboard itself.
Use the Three Wishes branding,
especially the new branding.
We have new boxes that we're using.
It is the most disorganized thought stream
that I've ever seen.
It's like incredibly amazing output.
Five point six is able to take that
five minute brain dump and turn it into
a plan.
It can pull the relevant data and brand
assets and it can turn it into something
polished and usable like this dashboard or
presentation or spreadsheet.
This feels like something you would
normally think a million dollar company
could build.
And you're like, we get this.
I have my business.
And if you look at that UI,
it's really clean.
Let me backtrack to that.
Yeah, that UI is really clean.
Looks like it's running.
It's not running local there,
so that's good.
and you're like, we get this.
I have my bespoke software system.
Five Point Six is also helping researchers
make discoveries.
Here is Bartosz again.
He'd been working on the same math problem
for three years and he couldn't solve it.
I decided, OK,
I'm going to try the new Codex Five
Point Six.
Codex was able to come up with a
completely new idea and just helped us
disprove the conjecture that we were
trying to prove for these three years.
Oh, I'm so excited of the discovery.
Five point six is able to take Bartosz's
prompt and divide the computation into
parallel workstreams with multiple agents
solving different parts of the problem.
And five point six is better at taking
your prompt and following it through all
the way to the end result.
I'll let Hiroki explain.
You see, with VFXV,
the work is no longer just staying on
the screen.
It's making a difference in the physical
world.
for everything from small businesses and
farmers to the world's best
mathematicians.
This is Hokkaido, Japan.
Wow.
Man, that's cool.
All right, so let's go back.
So they were actually part of the limited
preview.
So they got access to five point six
before it even came out.
Nice case study.
Let's look at the...
It's all dropped today.
Here we go.
So we talked about this last week here.
It's live.
It was a different site that,
not a site, but a different page.
I was looking for here.
This is all it.
see I want to see the comparison between
Sol Terra Luna actually no I might have
spoken I might have talked about it last
week anyway so there's Sol
terra and luna so soul is supposed to
be the big the big model very comparable
to fable terra is like medium luna's like
the uh the mini model of course you
know that's in co-pilot already
Yeah.
I haven't got a chance to use it
yet.
I used, what was it?
I got into a GPT, five point six.
I used that with GitHub copilot just a
little bit,
doing some work stuff and
The results were quite impressive,
kind of one shot, a real detailed summary,
some content I was putting together,
pulled it from different sources,
just told it what the subject was,
gave me a nice overview, gave me links,
gave me everything I needed.
Of course, I could have used the smaller,
lesser model.
but why not, right?
So I just jumped in.
I used Solterra.
Seemed pretty cool.
But what was I gonna talk about now?
All right, now I remember.
So first,
before we get right into Solterra, sorry,
GPT, five point six Sol.
Before we get into that,
I do wanna mention that I've been
using sub-agents.
So what happens is,
what happens is you have an agent,
you have to do a task, right?
But then that agent might not specialize
in certain things.
That agent's very generic.
It's specialized in doing the tasks that
you gave it.
What you can do is actually have
multiple agents.
So you can have a tester agent.
You can say, hey,
I want a tester agent to review everything
that doesn't know full context of what you
just built.
I want that agent to come in and
review your code, test your program.
Then you can have an agent come in
that's like, you know, marketing director.
come in and do some analysis you can
have a social media director I'm do some
analysis you can have um what else was
it yeah UX UI or graphic designer come
in do some analysis so the point is
that and then the cool thing is that
these agents sub agents that come in don't
actually have to have run the same model
that you're on so they could run a
different model
for a model that works best for that
scenario.
I've noticed that it helps a lot with
testing because when you do a lot of
one shots and you just put a prompt
in,
you run it and then you're actually going
through the program,
you're testing yourself and you're like,
man, this thing's kind of wonky.
It's not really what I want.
Well, guess what?
You can solve a lot of that by
just deploying your sub-agent,
having your sub-agent test before it even
comes back to you.
So it actually goes through iterations.
You could tell it to test a certain
amount of times.
You could tell your sub-agent to set up
a plan.
You could tell your sub-agent to actually
set up a plan,
but the way I use it is I'll
have it go into plan mode,
then I'll
have the sub agent analyze the plan,
make improvements on the plan,
then bills it out.
I've noticed that was a little,
it goes a little bit better.
So one thing I've been working on that
I've kind of used this concept of sub
agents is this a little tool for my
son.
Let me bring it up here.
So my son is in elementary school and
it's summertime.
So he's, uh,
we're trying to keep him on track with
his mathematics.
He's going into like fifth grade.
So in doing so we purchased like this
workbook for him to go through these
questions,
like answer questions and that's cool and
all,
but the workbook doesn't really like help
you with questions that you got wrong.
So I was like, you know what,
let's build kind of a study guide.
like that i would say study guide i
would say like a companion app right so
i'm over here talking i'm not even
clicking anything to get to get this
project up all right what did i call
it
I need an agent to write names for
my projects, because I'll write a project,
and I'm like, man, that's a horrible name.
So I called it Fast Prep App.
Horrible name.
But that's why I called it a folder.
Let's go in.
I'll just actually share.
Actually, you know what?
What am I doing?
I'll open up CLI first.
Then I'm going to start the app.
So I have it running localhost right now.
Here we go.
Let's see.
Let's see here.
All right, we're back.
So this went through a couple of
iterations.
This was like, yeah,
this was actually a lot of different
iterations, probably three or four maybe.
But what I did was I loaded up
the best workbook.
It was like a mathematics workbook.
I didn't load it up actually.
I just took the link from Amazon.
I was like, Hey, I use this workbook.
It understood, it understood the mission.
And the idea is that we gamify experience
to where he's using the workbook,
but he's also using this.
So it's kind of influenced by Khan
Academy, some gamification.
We had some ideas of doing a space
type of launch type theme.
I feel like that got a little confusing.
We brought in the UX UI graphic designer
agent to come up with this prompt,
this image, color scheme,
everything kind of flows.
Uh, there is a grownup dashboard,
so I can actually go in,
do some tracking.
Let's talk about his, um, abilities.
I get some feedback.
It is smart.
It has actually, uh, the test bank is,
or it's not the test bank.
The question bank is actually, uh,
generated through, uh, chat GPT, uh,
open AI actually gets smarter.
So as.
He answers questions incorrect or needs
help on certain things.
It'll actually adjust the, uh,
questions on a weekly basis.
All right.
So let's go in.
Let me not embarrass myself.
Some of this stuff on my knife.
All right.
So multi-digit operations.
That's kind of this thing for today.
Oh, that's how I practice.
There you go.
Multi-digit operations.
So.
Community garden has twenty four rows with
one hundred and fifteen seeds in each row.
How many seeds are planted?
OK, so it's multiplication.
I don't know.
Give me a clue.
OK,
the first twenty four times one hundred is
twenty four hundred.
So the answer should be a little bit
bigger.
See, this is nice.
Like it doesn't give you the actual
answer,
but it forces him to think through it.
which is really good.
That's kind of,
that's really what we wanted.
We didn't want to just like, Oh,
here's the answer.
Like if he didn't know the answer,
we want him to understand, um,
what it was.
So here it's like, Hey,
I need more help.
So at one hundred plus fifteen,
find twenty four times one hundred and
twenty four times fifteen.
Okay.
You click walk me through it.
So,
twenty-four times a hundred is twenty-four
hundred.
Twenty-four times fifteen is three sixty.
Add those parts up.
See, it still doesn't give you the answer.
Like,
even if you go all the way through.
So, I mean,
at the end of the day, it's very,
very simple.
We can say, hey, it's twenty-seven sixty.
Answer.
Nice work.
Tell Nova what strategy.
Playing your work.
So it really gets you thinking.
Let's see.
I'm so happy this.
Okay, I'll mess up this stuff.
So I saved that.
Actually, I never,
this is my first time using it, y'all.
Actually, no, I used it before.
So he's got a library of other things.
So he did that.
We actually, we just did that.
So here's different subjects within the
math realm that he can test out.
So it's fractions, same concept.
Give me clues, show an example,
walk me through.
Like which is greater than three-fourths.
Okay, cool.
All right,
and then you can collect stickers,
a little gamification, first try.
uh please use clues fraction friend
diffractions you go to your journal like
this is it's a companion app like it's
not meant to be the full experience it's
something that you use alongside the
workbook um so something fun fast prep app
we're gonna change that name for sure and
then what i'll do is i'll uh i'll
put this on my
In my Azure environment,
you can access it via web,
on the computer,
and I want him to test it out
and kind of be,
kind of go through it,
see what changes need to be made,
how it should be updated,
and kind of go through that experience.
So actually,
you know what we're going to do?
We will go to, uh, point six.
So let's check it out.
And we'll actually launch up a, uh,
Subagent.
This is going to be subagent.
That.
All right, we're here.
Okay, so we're in the Fast Prep app.
Let's do that.
So if you go to model,
you can choose Luna, Sol, Terra.
You can put extra high, max.
There's ultra about,
so I'll have access to ultra.
You know what, I'm not going to.
Let's just check.
Let's pick high.
What's the... So where did I leave off?
What's the latest on this app here?
I was looking at what was deployed,
what was built.
There's my, actually, yeah,
it's already in my Azure environment.
What am I saying?
I forgot about that.
I was running local hosts.
I did deploy it to my Azure environment.
Actually bring it up.
It's the same changes.
Yeah.
Yeah, I gave it.
So I deployed it into Azure,
but I didn't give it a specific domain.
So it gave me just a random Azure
domain that's here.
All right,
this hints the smart text test bank spoke
about the addition of the hero graphic.
Okay, so.
Sub agent.
All right.
And.
So when you're in GitHub code pilot,
you could do shift tab.
And then you see the color change here,
like gray, blue is plan mode,
purple is auto mode.
We're just looking for recommendations,
no need to plan.
There we go.
It's working.
So you see how it, it had the,
the sub agent is using Claude sign five
and it does that does that automatically.
So I could tell it which sub agent
to spin up.
So keep that in mind.
And I've been using GPT a lot lately.
I do want to kind of mix it
up this next week.
I want to use GPT.
I want to use the GPT as the
base,
but when planning and like setting up like
the initial structure of an app that I'm
creating,
I'm going to use a cloud Opus four
point eight to set up a plan and
then execute with.
So that's kind of like my plan.
What I'm seeing with the, uh, benchmarks,
a lot of reviews are saying that soul
is really good at taking over your
browser, using your computer,
like getting things done.
And you guys know what I've said in
the past, as far as GPT,
like GPTs for the streets, like, um,
all this like Oxford.
Higher education.
GPT just keeps it super real.
All right.
So launching a UX specialist to assess the
live learner and parent experience and
prioritize concrete improvements.
This is good.
Let's see.
Wow.
Again, as this loads,
just want to give a big shout out
to Fabflow,
our premium sponsor of Layer A Culture.
You know,
if you're interested in learning about AI,
learning about automation,
want to bring it into your business,
do a workshop.
I'm located in the Space Coast.
Definitely willing to do a virtual
workshop, willing to travel.
Hit me up.
Hello at layeraculture.io.
Get in touch with me.
Or just send me a message on social
media.
All right, here we go.
So UX sub-agent complete assessment,
expand question variety.
So each skill has at least three
questions.
Yeah,
there's only and try another never beat
the same item.
Okay.
It's like the ground dashboard parent
code.
That's cool.
All right.
Connect is a singing AI tutor API to
Nova's.
Hmm.
That way.
First one onboarding Nova.
Cool.
I like it.
And a clear session completes green after
reflection.
With a calm option to stop or continue.
Very nice.
Wow.
Wow, this is insane.
Like, the detail is so... Yeah,
it hasn't done this before.
This is new.
Okay.
Nice.
so i've implemented recommendations you
can let it go so with the cli
i've been what i've been doing a lot
lately is not only building but
testing also analyzing what I'm doing so
like with the um I think of a
good example even with like the social
media stuff I'm doing without that
automation so I did spin that up for
the real estate deal lab we got that
working
Um, but even like the copy,
as far as like the wording and like
the message that was going out,
I just spent up a sub agent to
work on specifically the copy,
like not even the automation part,
but like the words,
how the words were set up,
what it's actually saying,
how it's responding.
So that's a good way to, uh,
leverage the sub agent.
Let's see.
So it's implementing.
This is good.
One thing I did hear is that a
lot of people are saying Claude is
actually better at the UX UI design.
With me using GPT for the past two
weeks,
I haven't even used Claude for any UX.
That's something I might lean on.
Actually,
that's funny because the sub-agent that
spun up was called Sonic Five.
So it'll be interesting to see after we
implement what those changes look like.
But you know what, while that's going on,
we're going to let that run,
come back to it, check it out.
I want to do something fun with us.
So, so let's open this up.
Stop sharing for a sec.
It's going to be a long weekend, y'all.
It's going to be a long weekend.
Because I'm going to be... Yeah,
I'm going to be on Soul all weekend
long.
So... Okay.
Let's... Stop sharing.
As you can see,
it's already working on the stuff.
Let's go to... What's that?
So our new favorite spot,
our networking group real quick.
Let's try to create a website.
So first one, let's do it.
And soul is available in chat GPT as
well.
Like, not in ChatGPT,
but you know what I mean,
like the chat interface.
So we can go to high.
Why not?
look the name uh was it barefoot bay
i'm not gonna worry about it so remember
i asked you to make three mock-ups it's
making an image that's good because
sometimes you'll say mock-up and i'll like
it'll give you something else
So I like make websites cause it's,
you know, it's something creative.
Everyone needs a website.
Everyone like creates a website.
So it's a great,
it's a great case study or great use
case.
I should say.
So it's running.
Like this is ready already.
So let's check out.
Cool.
Let's check out.
So I mean, let's check out Nova.
Learn with Nova.
Oh, so man, see it.
Fifth grade launch pad.
I did put that name in.
It updated it.
So that's good.
All right.
So meet Nova, your summer learning guide.
Each visit is a calm,
fifteen to twenty five minute launch with
three small steps.
It was just like a little, you know,
low pressure.
Let's launch.
No, it looks the same.
Ready for today.
I picked this decimal decimal place value
because it's a good next step.
We'll do a warmup.
One practice question.
Quick wrap up.
See three steps.
Real easy.
Nice.
So start today.
Write seven and three hundred eight
thousandths in standard decimal format.
Give me a clue.
Write the number of digits in the
thousandths place.
Walk me through.
And then you also have the option to
pick try another.
Boom.
Okay.
Which decimal is greater?
So A, B, C, C, they're both equal.
Check my answer.
Nice work.
Okay.
Then I can go through,
save my wrap up.
This was great.
This was easy.
Launch completed.
Keep practicing.
How many times can I hit try another?
So this one, which is greater,
doesn't give me the ABC option.
It forces me to write it out.
I'll write the wrong thing here.
Not yet.
Nice work.
Easy.
I need to have a practice mode so
I don't mess my son's stuff up.
Cool.
Then, I'll go back to today.
So, warm up.
Practice.
Write about what helped.
Okay.
Seven actions this week.
Stickers earned.
Cool.
Back to this here.
All right.
So we got one website.
Cool.
Two.
Three.
Hmm.
Which one do I like?
let's see i really like this second one
yeah like this one save it okay let's
go into so actually let's make a project
real quick
Spin this up.
this quickly.
actually up.
I know what I'll do.
Assess the best
Gosh, typing's off.
Actually,
we're gonna talk about something while
this loads, but here it is.
Go to plan mode.
I'm just going to share my whole screen
because it'll be easier.
So what I'm looking at here, screen,
this one, sure.
All right, cool.
Real quick, there's a lot going on here.
So let's open this up.
You can't even see that.
Alright, so to the first invitation,
use the mock mockup.
Yes.
Is that school?
So that's running.
I want to show you guys something real
quick.
So handy.
I need to use this a lot more.
This thing's been hot fire.
Okay.
What now?
We're not worried about functionality
right now.
We're just going to see what it spits
out.
All right.
So real quick.
Man, this thing's really fast.
Hold up.
Let's just stay on it then.
For the first build,
be a single responsive page.
Matching the mock-up.
Yeah.
Mind you, this is running GPT-file.
GPT-file.
Yeah, it's very fast.
So it's telling me react, write,
type script.
Makes sense.
That's cool.
Um, the sub-agent that has been up, what,
which one did it use?
I wanted to test with a Claude probably
sub-agent, but it's all good.
It's never been this specific.
about the questions it's asking.
This is really good.
I'm just going to go with the
recommendation.
This is fun.
I'm excited.
Every time I go back to tell you
guys about this awesome app,
I get hit with another question.
So I'm like being careful anyways,
real quick.
So a lot of people are using Whisperflow.
This is actually a free app.
Whisperflow is really good because you
could use it on your phone,
but if you're on the computer all the
time, why not use the free app,
which is handy and it does the same
thing as Whisperflow.
You could pick a different model.
You download the model.
And then you can, as you can see,
like,
I don't want to use it that much,
but it is actually good.
I'm just the type of person,
like I have to be,
I have to type.
I don't use the voice as much as
I should.
It might be actually be helpful,
but I'm stubborn like that.
But if you're a type of person that
does like to use the voice and you're
on the computer a lot, um,
I don't know if they make this for
Mac, but definitely windows, uh, handy is.
Pretty cool.
And it's, uh, it uses AI models.
So it's pretty accurate as well.
I'm gonna find the website.
Oh, right here.
You want to get up?
So here you go.
Open source and free.
I should update it.
And I do need to use a lot
more.
Okay, cool.
So it's going to create this website.
I'm out myself.
Fire away.
Oh, cool.
So the in-app update.
What model do I have?
I have this one, the best one.
Accuracy and speed.
I actually do have the hotkey set up.
So you can set up a hotkey in
handy.
So mine is control.
like just put let's build all right so
i had to prompt it let it know
like yeah it's time to build um what
was i saying so i'd actually do have
the hotkey set up so i control space
where is it so it actually works in
any app that you're using don't see the
hotkey right in general here it is yeah
So here's the hotkey control space.
You could change that to whatever you
want.
Left control space.
Anytime I hit left control space,
as you can see right down here,
it starts transcribing.
So that works within any app on my
computer.
So I can do, let's see.
Oh, got to hold it youtube.com.
Easy.
So cool.
All right.
Back to our friend GPT, five point six.
So it's actually downloading stock
imagery, which it has never done before.
So when making these websites,
a lot of times it'll just,
what we'll do actually take the pieces of
the mockup and like,
just throw it in there.
It's very awkward and you have to kind
of just go through and have your own
hero images, add it yourself,
like in another round.
Not this time.
It's going out,
getting its own stock imagery.
So it's going to be interesting to see
what kind of images it gets,
how well it matches up to this mockup
that we have here.
That's what we're testing against.
Let's bring it out and get it ready.
This thing is about to show up and
show out.
So let's take it a minute here.
Thank you.
Let me go back to it.
That wasn't even there.
Did it look, Hey, hold on.
This is scary.
Okay.
okay that probably wasn't a real picture i
was like is that i was looking at
it here this picture down here like it's
crazy that looks like florida looks like a
straight up real storefront what are we
doing it's still working
But yeah, it's got some reviews, services,
book now.
Hey,
notice how it even wanted you to like
set up the booking through an app,
the integration functionality,
wanted all that to work.
Pretty interesting.
Let's see, where is it going?
It's also interesting here.
let's see it's like wow now i did
have the reasoning on was it high
So if the reasoning might be a little
lower, it could speed up the process.
Of course, you use less tokens.
Looks like it's almost there.
Cool.
Visual pass.
Browser automation.
I don't think I did I speak about
browser automation last week?
I think I did.
That's where it could actually go in,
open up your browser, look around itself.
I use that a lot with setting up
Facebook and Meta API.
This makes it easier.
I don't have to think about it.
Look at that.
It's actually just brought up the browser.
It's testing itself.
Looks like a desktop and mobile.
Looks like it's taking screenshots as
well.
It's probably taking a screenshot and then
analyzing the screenshot,
validating what it sees to make sure it's
all correct.
But again,
browser automation is something that
GPT-Five point six does very well.
So really excited to get in.
tackle a couple of things without having
to use API ease and all that fun
stuff and just let it, you know,
do its thing.
I did.
So another update is I did, um,
put in the request to put my social
media content generator or content engine
is the name of it.
Um,
that generates all the social media
content for Larry culture.
I did put the request in to get
that approved through Tik TOK.
It did push back and say that the
name of the app on my terms and
privacy policy page did not match the name
of the app I'm submitting for,
so I had to go back,
make sure that match put my terms and
privacy policy pages through GitHub CLI,
make sure that was all good,
and then I resubmitted.
I heard,
I got a response back from a tick
tock in about three days.
So cool.
Let's see.
It looks like this is ready.
Let's open this up.
I could just say, Hey, start up the,
uh, the dev box, but it's all good.
Is this the same?
Ooh, nice.
So another win for Larry culture people.
This is clean.
It's like, see,
it doesn't match the mock-up,
but it's thing.
I mean, yeah,
it doesn't match the mock-up,
but I'm not going to complain.
Think about what I could have done better.
I mean, this is dope.
I've never seen this before.
Oh, that's sick.
The font selection is nice.
That's a link.
Oh man, this is dope.
This still works very, this is like, wow.
This is clean.
so wow this is dope look at that
man this is definitely five point six is
the one y'all this is wow this is
insane i'm amazed so it didn't it didn't
get the uh facebook follow right i messed
that up but that's a fix this is
insane
Alright, y'all.
You know what to do.
It's time to build.
It's time to build, people.
This is... Wow.
I'm at a loss for words.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
Facebook, Instagram.
This is a really nice site.
Oh my gosh.
I I'm still,
I'm amazed by this part right here.
Yeah.
We're going to,
we're going to update a lot.
I mean, I definitely have to run.
So I'm going to run this through this
app.
This is insane.
i can't even think right now i can't
even think all right this is what i'm
gonna do you know what i didn't do
this for see i broke my own rules
always follow
I'm so inspired right now.
All right.
That's not even a good prompt at all.
It's really not.
It's a horrible prompt.
I'm gonna leave it at that.
Okay, let's see.
Let's go here.
That's perfect.
This site is insane.
Insane.
Just wow.
Views.
that is down here made with made with
sunshine where does it get this from made
with sunshine that's insane man we just
one prompted this from a flyer we're on
GPT, five point six soul, one prompt.
And it's so one agent and a sub
agent.
I'm not sure if the sub agent was
five point six soul as well.
It didn't specify.
So I'm just going to assume it was,
but this, this thing,
it's thing I did have,
what did I have the sub agent do?
I'm like looking at this prompt here.
that I used.
Please create a website based on this
mockup.
Start a sub-vision to assess the best
skills and GitHub repos to leverage in
this build.
That was it.
I'm literally gonna use the same prompt.
Man, let's see what it does with this.
Come on, this thing's taking forever.
What's going on, chat?
we go all right it's a bit much
that's a bit much we'll go with this
Go here.
There we go.
I'm going to change it around a little
bit.
Please update the app based on this
mockup.
Sorry, somebody just says best skills.
And we're supposed to leverage in this
build.
We go into plan mode.
Let's see what we got.
That website was insane, y'all.
That was nice.
See,
that's why it's important to follow the
process.
With the website or the app that I
made, I did not follow the process.
I didn't follow my own process of creating
the mockup, creating that visual,
picking the one you want, load that in,
give that guidance to your CLI,
get a much richer
product yep i have not been doing that
with some some of my builds i did
build the ai field guide i'll show that
real quick i don't know if i don't
remember if i showed there's so many
things going on i don't remember i showed
i showed it last week but i'm coming
out with these weekly ai field guides it's
kind of like a quick uh
a quick read just eight minutes this one's
all about mcps like what is an mcp
how to use it how to integrate best
practices you know the terms that you want
to understand got some links to different
repos actually i think i did talk about
this last week i don't remember but um
yeah i have another one coming out on
skills
this week tomorrow actually so look out
for that one you'll see the post
definitely comment skills you'll get the
link and i do want to convert these
to um like visual books as well like
this reading format um the reason i really
emphasize having this in this format
versus like a visual ebook or anything
like that a pdf is that
content in here guess what it's searchable
by Google by AI their culture becomes even
more reputable source of information so it
helps your SEO your AEO all that fun
stuff let's work on the plan
I'm still amazed by this website.
This thing is insane.
Insane.
Wow.
That's all I can say.
It's moving, reacting.
It's quite remarkable that you could do
this.
This I used to make websites with
WordPress.
Like I understand it's not this quick.
It's not that easy.
You run into all types of issues.
Certain plugins and tools just don't seem
quite right.
You got to sometimes go into a graphic
designer like Photoshop,
get your images kind of set up the
way you want.
You got to go through font libraries.
I've done it all.
It's a long process.
These icons,
you got to sometimes get these icons from
different sources.
Now this stuff right here,
I wouldn't even touch it.
I wouldn't even do that.
And man, this is amazing.
And I'm sure the mobile experience is on
point too.
Can I go to mobile?
I forgot to go to mobile and, um,
this, what is this thing doing?
What are you doing, sir?
Yes, it's revamping the entire website.
Did I?
I just told to do the plan.
Yeah, it's not doing anything right now.
It's just, it's there we go.
Reson dashboard map is existing app
features.
And I'm just going to do,
I'm going to do the whole shebang.
It's going to be design dashboard.
Recommended functionality right now.
This thing is cooking.
It's cooking.
So I knew you would come through.
So you did.
One more time for five point six.
So, what's next?
Did your thing.
Let's do a reddit scene.
Go to the reddits.
Gonna let this thing cook.
Over here on the other side.
I saw this reading.
Man, Ultra Max.
What's Pro Max?
The name of the scheme alone is a
disaster.
Yeah.
It's quite quite a disaster.
News.
Come on, people.
We got AI.
Stop making these ugly websites.
Let's see that.
It's twenty-four hours.
It's all the GitHub.
It's all LinkedIn.
Close second to table five.
Hmm.
One third of the cost of Fable V,
which is good.
Fable V is pretty expensive.
And you don't... Remember, it was on...
Not a trial, but like...
They were allowing you to use it until
the seventh.
I heard they extended it, though.
I don't even know.
Guys,
I know I said I was going to
use Fable V last week,
but then when I saw they were going
to stop it in July seventh,
I was like, no,
I'm not signing back up for that.
A couple days?
No way.
So it's fun.
It's done with plan mode.
It's gonna integrate some cool things into
that app.
We'll check it out and we'll sign out.
All right.
So I'll put tokens.
So this is a, it's talking about cost.
Hmm.
So there's Fable.
Very close.
There's Terra.
So, four point eight max.
Opus.
Sonic Five.
I didn't realize Sonic Five was actually
scoring better than Opus.
Hmm.
Let me check,
what do I have Sonic Five running on?
Check model here.
I do have, that's Sonic Five.
I got Max.
Yeah,
Sonic Five Max is actually scoring a
little bit better than Opus Max,
interesting.
Guys, this is why I like GitHub Copilot.
It allows me to use all these different
models.
Of course, it's going to cost.
It's all open source for open source use.
on my end.
But I do get the flexibility to play
around all these different models.
I cannot with these, unfortunately.
We'll see someday, someday.
Um, but definitely we have here.
Report one pro preview is there.
See,
but then like the hallucination rates are
pretty high.
We look at the performance though.
It is scoring better than Sonic Max in
the world.
Was this the real world?
Yeah.
So many,
probably gotta do an analysis on which
models work better for certain use cases.
Then form a model,
AI model board of directors around our
projects and see how that works.
Because I have been working with more like
simulation,
like looking at propensity models.
especially in the business world so real
quick see if i got time i got
time so we have this thing in the
manufacturing world called when okay so
when like highly volatile
environments you'll have what's called a
digital twin which is a virtual duplicate
of your dangerous and highly volatile
environment so that you're not putting
people at risk and people in danger be
able to experiment this happens in this
happens in um environments that are
dangerous like nuclear the nuclear or
energy industry right
This has been around for some time
already.
So it's quite common in the industry and
supporting article there.
So you have digital twins in
manufacturing, right?
And like industry industrial industries,
but there's this concept of a digital twin
in business.
With digital twin business strategy,
you test out business scenarios.
Simmons is already looking into this.
Simmons is actually really big on digital
twins.
Went to a manufacturing conference over in
Germany a couple years ago.
And they were like, literally,
they're the masters of robotic
manufacturing, digital twins,
all that crazy stuff.
So,
But this is still,
so this is still around like
manufacturing.
I'm talking about a digital twin to run
through business cases,
like to run through supply chain,
logistics, marketing scenarios, um,
investments like that type of digital
twin.
That's something I'm, uh,
I got on the list for building.
So it's interesting that I don't see
anything.
Wait.
Go to chat.
Let's see what the chat says.
Because Google was like, not the one.
Network design, capacity,
capital allocation, scenario planning.
Not just affiliates.
That's exactly what I'm looking for.
Yes.
Pepsi Cola.
The supply chain.
Simmons was involved.
So the Simmons seems really, well,
like I said, they've already,
they've already got the manufacturing side
of things down.
We'll just make sure that just flows right
into the business.
Using the same type of technology.
Yeah.
Simmons again.
Simmons.
see a lot of it's not manufacturing
operations finance market competitor
analysis interesting this thing's still
building
alright y'all I gotta call it I'm gonna
I'm gonna get back to this next week
let's wrap this up it's a good stream
it's a good uh
of a tech thursday it's gonna be a
long weekend with uh with soul gpt five
point six be a lot of fun all
right y'all know what to do get out
there build whether it's open ai whether
it's uh anthropic gemini let's get out
there and build y'all all right peace